[Música]
qué es más importante
la música o la fotografía la música es
magia
la fotografía es el único recurso
que actualmente hemos creado en como
devolvernos en el tiempo
estaba yo
tratando
de entender porque en nuestra sociedad
la fotografía se ha vuelto algo tan
importante y eso significa que ha pasado
de ser un hábito
a casi un emblema profesional en cada
uno de sus negocios de sus estilos de
vida y de su imagen la fotografía se
vuelve en algo tan importante que hoy en
día alguien compra un celular solamente
por tener una mejor cámara sí o no
ok ahora está estadio le voy a explicar
al estadio hay una producción
en eeuu y un amigo me dice más quiero
aprender a hacer mejores fotos ok coge
mi cámara y trata de hacer algo algo
chévere y me paro yo y empiezo a me
quedar tratando que él coja lo mejor y
fue interesante como yo al verlo uno
sabe cuando estaba haciendo mala foto
entonces yo lo vi y él decía no mira yo
como que realmente no soy muy bueno para
eso realmente creo que me va a calmar
del cielo porque muéstrame y cuando me
mostró
lo que él yo haciendo realmente iba muy
bien el único problema que él me dijo
era es que no puedo enfocar
no me puedo enfocar
y ese es mi problema con la fotografía o
que yo le decía
y por qué es tan importante está
enfocado
acaso es que uno nace enfocado
esta fue la fotografía que él me dice de
hecho se ve muy bien pero es un poco
desenfocado no está mal pero les voy a
explicar
es mejor con esta foto
usted se enfoca en lo que mejor quiere
en lo que más ama en sus mejores
experiencias en lo que más le gusta hay
gente que se enfoca por ejemplo en esta
lata de cerveza y le gusta la cerveza o
que está bien o bueno sea lo que sea que
esté allí más sin embargo una de las
cuestiones y las preguntas más
interesantes es el por qué es tan
importante este tema y lo voy a explicar
lógicamente con la cámara
estos somos nosotros estos son nuestros
estudios es uno de nuestra escolaridad
es una universidad son nuestras
experiencias y esto son nuestros
objetivos
lógicamente lo reconoce como un lente
pero profesionalmente se conoce como
objetivo al momento de que yo quiero
alcanzar algo estos dos elementos tienen
que estar completamente alineados y una
de las mejores formas para entender por
qué es tan importante la fotografía en
términos de explicar lo que le estoy
diciendo es que normalmente los alumnos
y la gente que está aprendiendo a ser
mejor su imagen a través de la
fotografía empieza con las preguntas más
comunes cómo puede hacer una mejor foto
cómo puede hacer que mejor tenga el
color que mejor tenga la nitidez que
mejor pueda capturar el momento que
mejor sea la edición que mejor sea la
postproducción cómo puede llegar a eso
los alumnos me preguntan a través del
tiempo este tipo de cosas y una de las
cosas que yo trataba de entender es que
lógicamente ellos no necesitan aprender
en cómo hundir un botón ellos lo que
necesitan aprender
es realmente porque yo al momento de
hundir un botón
dicen ellos hablando con sus compañeros
porque normalmente a una persona que le
enseñan no están muy abiertos porque yo
hundir este botón no puedo dejar de ver
personas tóxicas porque yo al momento
hundir esta palanquita aquí
no puedo dejar de pensar de que el éxito
tomará tiempo y tomará años y porque al
momento de yo mover
otro elemento de acá tendré que empezar
a pensar que perder será parte del
proceso se ha traicionado perder un
familiar perder un buen trabajo
quiero compartirles algo
la mayoría de personas que actualmente
se sientan en depresión a causa de que
han vivido la traición de que han vivido
la falta de unas mejores oportunidades
que han vivido la falta de perder un ser
querido yo quiero decirle que se
levanten piensen que hoy hace sol mañana
llueve no sabemos lo que nos pueda
esperar el destino y quiero decirles
algo
traten de llevar el proceso de acuerdo a
su tiempo ya su reloj de la vida
y espero que cada uno se convierta en
inspiración para los demás muchísimas
gracias
[Aplausos]